the president of haiti has been
assassinated in a nighttime attack
on his private residence president
gervais
moisey was shot dead when his home in
the capital puerto praise was stormed
by a group of armed men haiti's interim
prime minister also reported
that the first lady martin moyesi
has been hospitalized by the attack well
our
foreign affairs correspondent deborah
haynes
joins me now never a very happy country
haiti unfortunately
no and details are still emerging about
what happened overnight
the interim prime minister has made a
statement it seems as though
the attackers came in at about one in
the morning at this residential home and
shot dead
the president um joseph claude joseph
saying that he's going to be giving
a statement later and he he called the
attack
heinous inhuman and barbaric
but it comes at a time of increasing
political instability you'll remember
back in february the president himself
warned that
um there'd been an attempt on his life
an attempt to overthrow
his government um and a couple of dozen
people
were arrested so it's it's it's
happening at a point of
of huge instability the opposition
accusing uh had been accusing the
president of
um trying to turn the state into more of
a dictatorship
they'd had a failure to hold legislative
elections back in 2019 and so for the
last two years the president has
has been ruling by decree and his actual
term it was a five-year term
the length of that has also been
disputed this is a man if you
talk a little bit about um the now
deceased president
who came into politics in 2015
he'd never been a politician before he
was hand-picked
by the previous president he's actually
um a banana entrepreneur a banana
exporter
a businessman um and in those elections
they were disputed in 2015 into 2016
and he was only actually declared
president in
february 2017. it's a five-year term
and he believe he had believed then his
supporters believed
that he should be in office until next
year but his opposition
very much thought he should be out
already and that has
fueled the anger the protests that we've
seen on the streets
also allegations of corruption this is a
hugely
um turbulent time anyway and um analysts
are very worried about
potential further instability um it
seems as though there will be this
address later on today from the interim
prime minister
and the security forces will be wanting
to try to
keep calm and avoid a further escalation
thank you very much indeed for that
update on the situation of haiti one of
the poorest countries in the world debra
haynes thank you